[Music]
Nihao Honolulu
so can you in two words describe what
you're doing here today
ilan two words yeah well to be honest
with you I'm here to meet women kids
yeah we're all children of God murder
your way to freedom love is not the
answer
stop doing drugs and start killing these
are used to control things but not the
minds of others this is for children
their God would on the opah you can
defend yourself if someone were to
violently attack you which will happen
someday you gotta pass on you got to
pass it on to get it on I get off
there's so many Puerto Ricans nowadays
that you're like hey hey go back to
Puerto Rico
hey Puerto Ricans I'm walking in just
for the kids wait can you cut that out
helper for all nah just me
you know what we're gonna I wish I had a
good one to say but I don't the fine
jerk got a beautiful picture why they
drew so I didn't draw that those nothing
like me really my lips yeah Mary you can
turn pulling on just can't turn it off
it's where I get all my checks pin here
we are here's the African art like a
rough boy
[Music]